- You're also, I have to mention
this 'cause I'm a musician.
I love this.
I'm excited about it, so you're also-
- This is what I'm nervous
to talk about with you.
- What?
I'm so excited!
You're in an upcoming series
about George Jones and
Tammy Frigging Wynette.
(audience cheering)
I'm so excited.
What, why are you?
- What?
So you're singing in it.
I'm so excited.
And she has a very specific tone,
so it's like, I'm so excited.
First of all, do you only like
playing people named Tammy?
- I know, right?
If I had a nickel for
every Tammy I played,
I'd have 10 cents.
- I'm very excited about that.
Are you so stoked about this?
- I'm stoked.
I love it.
I mean that's, I did, you know,
Mike Shannon plays George Jones.
We worked with Ron Browning.
He's a vocal coach from
Nashville on the music.
It was very stressful.
So it's one thing, it's
probably the most nervous thing
that I makes me even talking about,
it gives me like hives.
But I drank a lot of bourbon
(Kelly laughing)
and I got through it.
I got through it.
- And not because you had
a cold or sinus infection.
You were just like.
- We called it my medicinal tea.
At 10:00 AM I was like, I'd
like a medicinal tea, please.
- I cannot wait to see the George Jones,
Tammy Wynette thing.
That's so cool.
- We'll get it to you first.
- I cannot wait to see it.
You're gonna be incredible.